à l'heure où l'on parle de la 5g
certaines communes comme bullion sont en
zone blanche
mais cette faiblesse du réseau sera
bientôt une histoire ancienne vendredi 9
avril cédric au secrétaire d'état chargé
de la transition numérique a signé aux
côtés de la députée aurore bergé et du
maire de la commune
une convention pour déployer la 4g dans
le village quand vous êtes à l'intérieur
de la mairie lindor vous avez zéro barre
pour appeler ne serait-ce le 17 ou le 18
mo situé dans certaines zones de la
commune où il ya des activités sportives
ou périscolaires vous pouvez même pas
appelé les gendarmes
autre but you est une zone protégée et
possède des bâti traditionnel pour
implanter ses antennes il faudra
respecter le paysage
maintenant il ya des travaux très précis
qui sont menées pour qu'on les voit
moins pour qu'elles soient pas visibles
pour qu'on ne les voit pas quand elles
sont à proximité d'une église ou d'un
bâtiment historique
donc on a la capacité de faire en sorte
de ne pas dégrader
l'espace environnement tout en
implantant des antennes la commune aux
concertations avec les services en
charge de l'installation a déjà
identifié deux sites pour implanter les
antennes un bottillon simple entrée dans
une zone boisée un peu en hauteur de
façon à pouvoir orienter l'antenne sur
le hameau et puis dans le centre bourg
on se situe de rêve dans une zone qui
est l'ancienne station d'épuration qui
est un petit peu en recul au niveau des
habitations
au total ce sont seize pylônes qui
seront installés d'ici deux ans dans les
yvelines
l'opération est entièrement financé par
l'état